ETHAN KAY: If we were to
think about the biggest
problems affecting our world,
any socially conscious person
would have to include poverty,
disease, and climate change.
And yet, there is one
thing that causes all three
of these simultaneously,
that we pay
almost no attention to, even
though a very good solution
exists.
It's one of the most
unreported stories about life
in the developing world.
And I'm here to
tell you about it.
In 2005, I was working with
a rural community development
NGO in Osmanabad, India.
As part of my work, I conducted
in-depth interviews with women
in their villages.
I interviewed Mina in a
village called Bamaniwadi.
At the time, she was cooking
lunch for her husband
and her two-year-old daughter,
who was crawling next to her
as she cooked.
Like most women in
the village, Mina
was cooking on an
indoor open fire.
Her one-room hut was
thick with smoke.
By 30 minutes into the
two-hour interview,
everyone's eyes were watering.
We were coughing.
And I could barely breathe.
I was horrified when I realized
that Mina and her family
have to deal with
this on a daily basis.
Yet, this is how nearly
half the world lives.
Three billion people cook their
meals on indoor open fires.
When we think about the biggest
killers of people living
in poverty in the
developing world,
we think about AIDS,
tuberculosis, and malaria.
We don't think
about the kitchen.
Yet, every year, over
four million people
die from household air
pollution from cooking
on a smoky open fire.
It's like wiping out
half the population
of New York City every year.
Household air pollution
kills more people
than AIDS, tuberculosis,
and malaria combined.
How does this happen?
Day after day, for up
to six hours a day,
women like Mina cook their
meals on an indoor open fire.
And when they do, they
breathe in the toxic smoke
from the flames, which leads
to fatal respiratory diseases.
Half a million of these
four million deaths
are children under
the age of five.
The biggest killer
of young children
globally is smoke
from the open fire.
So there's the serious problem.
And yet, we're
completely ignoring it.
In addition, these open
fires have an enormous impact
on our environment.
The smoke from
these fires contains
something called
black carbon, which
is the second biggest
contributor to climate change.
According to the latest
statistics on black carbon,
cooking on a smoky open fire
creates more black carbon
than all of the world's
cars and trucks combined.
So here's the situation.
We have three billion
people cooking
on smoky open fires with
devastating health and climate
consequences.
Solving this problem would
have an enormous impact
on global health
and climate change.
And there is a solution, the
production and distribution
of ultra-clean cook stoves.
These cook stoves dramatically
reduce smoke emissions
and cut fuel consumption.
And I'm going to turn it
over to my colleague, Ryan,
to tell you more about
how this cook stove works.
RYAN GIST: Thank you, Ethan.
And thanks to Google
for hosting us today.
So how does this product work?
We've got one here.
And the process starts
with the user feeding fuel
into the side of the
stove and lighting it,
just the same way they would
their traditional open fire.
They use the same fuels,
whether it be wood or crop
residue or even animal dung.
But the difference
compared to the open fire
is that when they light the
fire and heat is released,
a small portion of
that heat energy
is converted into
electrical energy.
And that electricity is
used to turn a small fan,
force feeding air into
the fire, bringing oxygen,
and making for very
efficient clean combustion.
The smoke is almost
eliminated, over 90% reduced.
And the fire burns much
more efficiently, twice
as efficiently.
So that for any one
given cooking task,
the user only needs to
feed half as much fuel.
But it gets even
better than that
because as the fire builds and
more heat energy is released,
more electricity is
generated, to the point
where it's more electricity
than is required for the fan.
And that surplus
electricity can be
passed to a USB port on
the side of the stove.
You can see in this
instance, we're
using a small LED
light, which can
be used to light the
cooking area or the home
for the evening.
But even more importantly, in
areas of sub-Saharan Africa
and India where mobile
phone adoption has outpaced
the electricity grid, it still
generates enough electricity
to be able to
charge a cell phone.
So it's a really dramatic change
from other ways of solving
this clean cooking issue.
And it provides Ethan and his
team a totally different value
proposition.
This technology is enabled by
an electronic device called
the thermoelectric generator.
And there's a lot
of ways to think
about a thermoelectric
generator.
But today, let's consider it
like a solar panel for heat.
So rather than converting
light into electricity,
we're converting heat
into electricity.
And this occurs due to a pair
of metals inside the device that
have a very unique property.
When one of them is hot
and the other is cold,
they pass electrons
to one another.
So the fire provides a very
convenient source of heat.
And the cooler ambient air can
be used to cool the cold side.
And that's the real
elegance in this design.
It's the dual use
of this fan flow.
That same air that we
talked about bringing oxygen
to the fire to make it burn
cleanly and efficiently
is the air that's used
to cool the cold side.
And it gets preheated
in this process.
So the fire gets what it needs.
And the user is provided
with on demand electricity.
So again, this just radically
changes the value proposition
that Ethan can offer
to our customers.
ETHAN KAY: At a
retail price of $50,
the stove pays for itself in
seven months, based on fuel
and electricity savings.
And it gets even better.
Since the stove reduces
carbon emissions,
we can take advantage of
existing carbon credit offset
programs to make this stove
affordable to the poorest
of the poor.
You may wonder why I'm
telling you all this.
I'm not an engineer.
I didn't design this stove.
I'm just a guy from Cleveland,
Ohio, who has trouble making
a grilled cheese sandwich.
But after my
experience in hundreds
of smoky homes
across rural India,
I set myself the goal of
trying to solve this problem.
So I tried to help
the NGO that I
was working with to
distribute cook stoves to Mina
and her neighbors.
We marketed a stove by a
large British oil company.
But it had some problems.
It required expensive
fuel pellets, which people
didn't want to pay for.
And it needed electricity,
which many villages didn't have.
So it sucked.
And understanding why it sucked
was my PhD thesis in Management
Studies from Oxford.
What this large British oil
company didn't understand
was how people in
rural India interact
with their cooking environment.
They didn't think about the
significance of the cook stove
on daily life.
What I saw in the
months and months
that I spent in rural India was
that for technology to work,
it has to be
culturally appropriate.
And it's not just this big
oil company that got it wrong.
So many previous attempts at
improving the lives of people
living in poverty have failed.
And I came to realize that
many of those failures
did not employ a
user-centered approach.
They failed to take into
account how real people live,
their real behaviors
and cultural practices.
So how to crack the
problem of cook stoves?
When I really thought
about the people
that I spent time
with in rural India,
I realized that the stove
was not just an appliance,
but the spiritual
center of their home.
They saw this fire
in their kitchen
as a domestic god, a
deity, and the flame
as a spiritual messenger
between them and heaven.
They prayed before
the stove daily
and created rangoli,
artwork they
drew around the stove
with colorful chalk
to consecrate it, to
make it a sacred object.
In much of the developing
world, the wife
is responsible for the cooking.
And she and the children
disproportionately
suffer the health effects.
But the husband
controls the money.
So how could we get both
the wife and the husband
to want to purchase
a clean cook stove?
Most men in rural India
have a mobile phone,
which they hope will help
them improve their livelihood.
But many of them can't
charge the phone at home
because they don't
have electricity.
Usually, there's
a commercial kiosk
a few miles away
where people have
to pay to charge their phone.
In Kenya, people pay $3 to $4
a month to charge their phone.
That's two days' salary.
That 7% of their income
just to charge their phone.
But since our stove generates
more than enough electricity
to charge their phone, men
really like this stove.
There are also some
design considerations.
People in different regions
cook different dishes.
In Guatemala, they
make tortillas.
And so they need a really
big cooking surface.
In Ghana, they stir
large pots of stew.
And so they need a sturdy
stove that won't topple.
In north India, they make roti.
And so they need a
really hot flame.
So our stove needs
to be customized
to serve different cultures.
So how do we get these
stoves to people?
Why don't we just
get a billion dollars
from Warren Buffett or Google
and throw millions of stoves
at rural India?
It's not a good idea.
People don't want charity.
The people in rural India,
just like you and me,
want their cherished
objects to be
the result of their effort and
their economic achievement.
Also, if they got the stoves
for free and they broke down
and they couldn't
fix them, they'd
go right back to cooking
on their open fire.
We started designing
our business in 2010
and thought that surely by now
we'd have a scaled up business.
But we didn't anticipate
all of the hurdles that
come with operating in rural
India and sub-Saharan Africa.
For instance, in Uganda, the
tax rate on imported cook stoves
is 60%.
That means a $30 cook stove
costs the end customer $48.
So we've had to get creative
and scrappy and lucky.
Last January, the
vice-president of Uganda
unexpectedly visited one
of our stove demonstrations
in Kampala.
He wanted to buy a stove,
but wanted to bargain down
the retail price.
We bargained back.
We told him if his
government reduces
taxes on this
life-enhancing product,
we can reduce the cost
of the stove for him
as well as the rest
of the country.
After a year of
negotiations, we've
managed to cut our tax rate
in Uganda by nearly half.
We've also had some
unexpected setbacks.
Our Ghana manager tried to
be culturally appropriate
and ate a bush cat grilled
in his honor on the stove.
Jan spent the next
month in the hospital.
We've also had some
unexpected surprises.
Our most successful sales agent
in India is also a magician.
When demonstrating the stove,
Himanshu flicks a lit match
from five feet away into
the mouth of the stove.
And it immediately
lights the flame.
Ryan and his engineering
team have also
had to get creative and scrappy.
RYAN GIST: Yeah, we have.
And creative design
is one thing.
But we've had to get creative
with the whole supply chain,
as well.
When your customers are very low
income and tightly constrained
by their purchasing power,
pricing is critical.
And as Ethan described, with
some of the taxes and tariffs
that are imposed on us in
the markets we operate,
there's a really powerful
compounding effect
on the initial cost of goods.
When we first got
started in all of this,
we took a very standard
approach to component sourcing
for the stove.
We understood our system.
We knew what each
piece needed to do.
And we worked with
vendors to find
catalog parts that
could get each one
of those individual jobs done.
We weren't experts in
thermoelectric generators.
We weren't fan
designers or experts
in power electronics
or metallurgists.
We took their word
for it, really.
But over the course
of the project
and learning more
about the task at hand,
we realized to really
delight our customer
and to provide the product at
a price that they can afford,
we had to do all those things.
And so we've asked all the
members of the engineering
team and the development
team to build expertise
in totally new areas for them.
I can walk you
through one example.
At the core of the
system is the fan.
And in the first
generation of the stove,
we talked to every fan
manufacturer we could.
And we identified a fan
that was a computer cooling
fan, that was about right
for our application.
These fans are mass produced
with all the benefits
of economy of scale baked in.
They appear in computers by
the millions the world over.
So at about $3 a pop,
we thought we were
getting a pretty good deal.
The problem is that even $3
is a really significant chunk
of our overall
cost of production
for this affordable stove.
And on top of that,
the fan was never
designed for our application.
So we had to actually purchase
a slightly larger version,
knowing that it would run
not at peak efficiency.
That simply wasn't
going to work.
So we dug in, and like
I said, became experts.
We studied compact fan design.
We brought in tools to
do aerodynamic analysis
on the duct work
inside of our product.
We learned how to
control the fans.
We even learned how to
design the electric motors
that power of these fans.
And the end result was that we
were able to short cut the fan
manufacture entirely, source
a motor that could do the job
for about $0.50, custom design
our own fan blades that could
be injection molded
for about $0.10,
run the fan from our
own power electronics,
and incorporate the rest of
the housing into the plastic
enclosure already
part of the product.
And so in the end, a
component that cost $3 we now
can make for under $1, saving
over 70% on that component
alone.
And we fought similar sourcing
battles across the product
all over, in the metals in
the stove, the electronics,
the thermoelectric.
But the point is that we really
had to dive and become experts.
And pricing is one half.
But we also need to
understand the customer.
And we pushed
really hard to have
every engineer on
the development team
pay equal attention to our
users and the user needs.
We spent weeks and months in
the field with Ethan's team,
observing cooking, watching
household energy management,
and sitting down with
the cooks to really learn
how they interact
with the stove, what
the potential pitfalls
and pain points might be.
We learned a lot
in this process.
I always say a week
in the field can
be more informative
than a month in the lab.
And even as recently
as late last year,
we've made some pretty
key understandings
during this process.
One specific incident
late last year,
we were watching people cook.
And in some regions,
for certain dishes,
rather than just an hour or
two hours worth of cooking,
they cook nearly all day,
for three, four, five
hours at a time.
And during these really
long duration burns,
some of the fuel doesn't
quite fully combust.
And you build
charcoal in the stove.
This charcoal builds
up and eventually,
over the course of
four hours or so,
can fill up the whole chamber.
And so you need to remove
that charcoal in order
to keep cooking,
to feed fresh fuel.
Well, the problem
is we've now got
a cook who's pulling out
a large burning stick
and essentially holding an
open fire now in their hand,
emitting all the smoke
that an open fire does.
And what we saw was that during
this process of pulling out
the burning fuel,
clearing the charcoal,
and putting it back
in, all that smoke
we had just saved over
the last three hours
was now emitted into the home.
So we knew it was an issue
that had to be solved.
We came back into the lab.
We built out capability to
do long duration burns here
in our labs for hours on end.
We sourced the
appropriate fuel to be
able to simulate conditions.
And we re-tuned the
entire injection scheme
to make sure that not
only the flame was burning
clean and efficiently, but
this charcoal was fully
combusted and used.
We eliminated the need for this
charcoal clearing exercise.
And so I think we're close.
We've got the right product.
We're zeroing in
on the cost target.
And it's really up
to Ethan and his team
to go get these stoves into all
the households that need them.
ETHAN KAY: Our
business is on track
to be self-sustaining
and profitable.
But it's going to take a
lot of patience and capital
to get there.
Fortunately, we've
built this patience
into our business model.
In addition to selling cook
stoves in the developing world,
we also commercialized a line
of camping products, which
we sell to outdoor recreation
customers in the US
and over 70 other countries.
We call this business
model parallel innovation.
This is not a TOMS shoes,
one-for-one handout model.
This is about reinvesting
near-term revenue
from the sale of
our camping products
to incubate the emerging
markets business until it's
commercially self-sufficient.
I'd love to talk to
any of you afterward
about how we can make this
business model even more
sustainable.
Around 1440, Johannes
Gutenberg, an entrepreneur
with a great beard, set out
to develop the printing press.
At the time, scribes
wrote books by hand.
Yet, the challenge of inventing
a printing press were daunting.
Civilizations had been
trying for thousands of years
to mechanically
reproduce texts--
the Minoans, the
Greeks, the Chinese.
Yet, it never took off.
In each case, there
was something missing
that was crucial to
mass uptake, whether it
was the invention of
paper or the alphabet
or expanded literacy or
buy-in from religious elites.
It wasn't just a
technology problem.
For printing to catch
on, all of these
technical and cultural
and social elements
needed to align.
Gutenberg understood the need
to develop a contextually
appropriate solution.
For instance, he
designed his typeface
to look like
scribal handwriting,
so that it was
consistent with the look
of valuable illuminated
manuscripts.
He didn't want to break
with existing culture,
or else he'd alienate
prospective buyers.
Also, since the church
controlled the book industry,
he, just like us
with cook stoves,
needed to get religious
leaders on board.
He made his first product
the Bible, which as we know,
went viral.
This was one of the most
important inventions
in world history because it led
to the explosion of knowledge.
But it only took off because it
was consistent with the social,
cultural, and religious context.
Today, as in Gutenberg's
time, in order
to design solutions
for any community,
particularly in the
developing world,
it's important to acquire
an in-depth understanding
of local users and
their motivations.
It's important to understand
how real people live,
their culture,
and their beliefs.
If we do this
intelligently, we can
solve some of the world's
most serious problems.
This is the BioLite home stove.
Ryan and I are 34.
By the time we're 40,
let's make sure there
are millions and millions
of these stoves saving lives
across India and Africa.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name is Chris.
Health data is notoriously
difficult to gather.
So could you talk a little bit
about the methodology for how
you quantified this
problem, like how
you're attributing these
premature deaths to the smoke?
Is it condition-based?
I would love to hear
more about that.
ETHAN KAY: Do you want me--
RYAN GIST: Yeah, you
should take that.
I mean, we don't develop
that data ourselves.
But you could speak to it.
ETHAN KAY: So the data on the
magnitude of deaths attributed
to household air pollution are
provided by the World Health
Organization.
And the primary deaths are
both respiratory disease
and cardiovascular disease
and cardiopulmonary disease.
There's been a big challenge
in the global public health
community, not around
attributing deaths
from these diseases, but
rather in quantifying
the health impact of stoves like
these to address those deaths.
So the public health
community argues
that you need a 90% reduction
in particulate matter
in order to mitigate the
risk of respiratory disease.
And if we can nerd
it out for a second,
the relationship between
respiratory disease and air
pollution is not linear.
It's logarithmic.
So you need literally a 10x
reduction from an open fire
in order to have a 50%
reduction in the risk
factor for respiratory disease.
And so the first thing that
we as an organization did
was, have had to validate
in our own lab, which
is built to the same standards,
and Ryan can elaborate on this,
as the US EPA that our stove
produces smoke in laboratory
conditions by at least
90%, which we've done so,
and have also had the EPA
and the government of India
and other independent bodies
independently verify that.
We then took stoves to the
field and have done studies
with independent testing groups
like Berkeley Air Monitoring,
which is a group
out of California,
to validate that with the types
of fuels that people are using
and the way that they're used to
feeding the fuels that it also
achieves a 90% reduction
in respiratory disease.
And we've done that, as well.
And then the final step
is the gold standard
in research methods, which is
a randomized control trial.
And so for the last
2 and 1/2 years,
BioLite has been participating
in the world's largest
randomized controlled trial of
the health impact of this cook
stove on young children.
And it's a National
Institute of Health funded
study, administered by Columbia
University's School of Public
Health and the Ghanaian
Ministry of Health.
And the results aren't out yet,
but that's the third piece,
validating that these stoves
have impact on villagers.
RYAN GIST: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hey,
how does the stove
compare with the typical
rocket stove design?
Is it basically the same thing
or a completely different idea?
RYAN GIST: Well, totally
different in that it's
a forced draft stove.
So it does have a rocket
stove architecture.
And for everybody
else out here that's
not familiar with
the rocket stove,
it's a basic stove
architecture that's essentially
like a chimney in your house.
You've got this L
shape that's properly
sized in terms of
the inlet and also
the outlet of the
top of the stove.
And so as the fire
releases heat,
it induces this natural
draft, pulls air
in from the ambient
through the fire,
and then comes out the top.
And the other thing that's
important in the rocket stove
architecture is
all the insulation
that's built around that.
And so there's a
bunch of insulation
between this outer wall and
the hot wall inside the chamber
so that all the heat really
gets directed directly
to the cooking surface rather
than lost out to the ambient.
So a rocket stove can
improve the fuel efficiency.
But the problem is, for each
gram of fuel that you burn,
you're still emitting
all this smoke.
You're not really getting
complete combustion.
You're not getting intimate
mixing between the oxygen
and the fuel molecules.
And the fan, with
our injection array,
getting turbulent mixing
at each jet location really
is what changes that.
So we've used the
rocket architecture
to improve the fuel economy.
And then we've used our
air injection technology
to make sure each
gram of fuel released
is 90% less particulate matter.
AUDIENCE: And did you
consider any exhaust solutions
because burning the fuel
more cleanly is one good way.
But another obvious thing
that pops into my mind
is, if the smoke gets
exhausted outside
rather than just being released
in the air inside the house.
RYAN GIST: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Would there be a
plug-in or some kind of a way?
Or is that just not
practical with the way
that these stoves
are typically used?
RYAN GIST: It can be
practical in certain markets.
Ethan showed you
the cooking style
in Latin America, which is
on a wide plancha stove.
And those are usually inbuilt
stoves that are fixed in place.
And adding a chimney
to a stove like that
can really dramatically
improve indoor air pollution.
There are a couple
problems with that.
I mean, for one,
you're not really
addressing the
environmental impacts
of all that black carbon.
The black carbon is
a huge forcing factor
on global warming potential.
So we'd rather burn
it to completion
than just dump it outside.
But also, there are cultural
contexts in daily use modes
where the stove really
needs to be flexible.
And people need to be able
to put different cooking
implements on top of it.
So a compact, portable stove
like this is much more useful.
It requires a lot
less behavior change
than something that's
inbuilt with a chimney
that pipes the flow
outside of the home.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Do you do all
your manufacturing here?
Or do you try to have a local
supply chain in the countries
where you're selling the stoves?
RYAN GIST: We can tag
team this one, I guess.
I mean, currently the stoves
are produced in China.
That's the cheapest way we
can generate them and have
the quality control that we need
for the electronics components.
We're working in both
India and East Africa
to find options
for local assembly
and some local production of
the metallic parts of the stove.
You can imagine that the cast
iron pieces and the metal
pieces are heavy.
They're expensive to
ship around the world.
So bringing those pieces of
the production in-country
can reduce our tariff rates.
It can invigorate local
businesses in those countries
and also reduce the
shipping costs for us.
But in order to keep
the quality where
it needs to be on
our electronics
components and the fan and
some of the internal geometry,
we'll probably keep most
of that in southern China
for the time being.
AUDIENCE: Hey, there.
Thanks for coming.
I'm curious about
a couple of things.
One is around your supply chain.
I'd like to hear some of
the challenges of getting
this product to the
people that need it.
And things break.
Once they break, what kind
of challenges and what kind
of solutions have you come up
with for helping the people
there repair their own devices?
ETHAN KAY: Sure.
So the first time that
we shipped as pilot units
to India, I think
40% of them ended up
smashed by the time they
reached the end user.
And it turned out that
they were being thrown off
the top of trains and buses.
And so we had to augment our
packaging to address that.
One of the biggest challenges
in the business model
is what we call last
mile distribution, which
is, once you've
left a city and have
to get the product
to a villager's home,
the roads, if there are roads at
all, they're very poor quality.
And so we've designed these--
I don't know if any
of you have seen
on the back of motorcycles,
there are these pizza boxes
sometimes in the
developing world.
Domino's delivers their
pizzas with these, like,
boxes on the back of motorbikes.
And so we've designed
a similar box
for transporting our stoves on
motorbikes because our village
distribution agents
ride motorbikes
to get stoves to end user.
And we've even
designed an apparatus
that can allow you to
carry six of these stoves
on the back of the bike
in a pretty safe way.
Beyond that, we really think
that customer engagement
starts at the point of sale.
It doesn't stop then.
And so we've invested really
heavily in after sale service.
And so, I'll just share
a couple aspects of it.
The first is that we've set
up a call center in each
of our markets that follows up
with every one of our customers
who's purchased the stove,
first a couple weeks
after the point of sale to make
sure that they were properly
trained when they
were sold the product
and to make sure they don't
have immediate user issues, then
at six months and a year
after to find out, do they
like the stove, is it delivering
on its feature set, would they
recommend it to
others, et cetera.
And then in addition to
that, Ryan and his team
have designed the stove to
be very, very easy to repair.
And maybe you can
elaborate on that.
RYAN GIST: Yeah, no, I'm
glad you brought it up.
I was going to add
to that at the end.
But essentially, there's two
main halves of the stove.
There's the metallic
stove body that's
the heat containing
functional part, and then
the power electronics in
our power pack back here.
And by making those two
somewhat modular and really
simple to join to
one another, we
can identify the
particular issue
that a user might
have, and address that
with just a component
replacement that our field
agents are very capable of
implementing in the field.
And so if the stove has
been in use for many years,
maybe there is some
corrosion inside here
and they need a new stove body.
We can replace that with
the existing power pack
they have at a reduced cost.
If someone's thrown some liquid
inside the thing or someone's
grabbed it and somehow
damaged the power pack,
we can bring a
replacement power pack
and split that supply
chain up a little bit.
ETHAN KAY: And currently,
our average repair time
across markets is three
days from the point
that the customer experiences
an issue to the point
that it's been solved for.
So we've tried to decentralize
after sales service
to allow for very
efficient repairs.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ETHAN KAY: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I have two questions.
First, I want to know
if you had considered
creating a bigger opening
for bigger pieces of wood.
And the other question is,
could you please describe again
how you reduced the smoke.
RYAN GIST: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RYAN GIST: I'll
take both of those.
You must be a
stove user yourself
because that's the number one
feedback we get in the regions
that we operate is like, we
need a bigger fuel mouth.
Oftentimes, people are literally
tearing limbs off of trees
and lighting the end of it
and continually feeding that
into the stove.
So that's definitely something
we're working to optimize.
There is a new version
of this stove that
will be coming out this year.
The mouth has been
increased a little bit.
But the trade there is
that as you open the mouth,
you're now exposing all
that heat and radiation
to the environment.
And that's really one of the
key factors of the rocket stove
architecture that we
talked about a minute ago
is that by containing
all of that
and not allowing the radiation
to get out into the world,
you're improving the fuel
efficiency of the stove.
So there's kind of
a balancing point.
And we're trying to find out
exactly where that point is.
We believe it's a little bit
larger than what you see here,
but not so much larger that we
really lose fuel efficiency.
And in terms of
eliminating the smoke,
it's really just chemistry.
I have a background in
aerospace engineering.
I did combustion engineering
at my previous job.
And it's really all about
getting intimate contact
with fuel molecules
and oxygen molecules,
and making sure they
can interact in a place
where they're nice and hot.
And so in a typical
fire, you've got a bunch
of fuel coming off of the wood.
And then it's got to
pull air from the outside
to react with that.
But there's too much fuel
in the middle and too much
air on the outside.
And somewhere in between
is where the flame happens.
And where there's too
much fuel, often that
will cool off and
then be unburned.
And that's the particulate
smoke, either in droplets
or solid particles
that get emitted.
By injecting air
at high velocity,
we swirl all that stuff together
so that the big chunks of fuel
and the big pockets of air
get intimate with each other
and can really mix and
allow that chemistry
to happen in the environment
where it's nice and hot.
And you get complete combustion.
All the fuel gets converted.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ETHAN KAY: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks for
coming and talking to us.
Two questions.
What are the metallic
parts made of,
like the ones outside
the bigger parts?
And then how does
the financing usually
work for people who are
buying these stoves?
RYAN GIST: Sure.
There's a combination
of different alloys
in the stove that are used
in different locations,
based on the temperature
that they're exposed to,
based on the
chemistry in the wood,
whether it be sulphur or
chlorine that may be attacking
it in a corrosion mechanism.
You see a lot of
cast iron on here.
Cast iron is attributed
to durability
in the markets we operate.
And people really
trust that material.
So we always use cast iron
on the top of the stove.
In this version, there was some
cast iron in the main chamber.
We've since gone away from
that and gone to an alloy
that we can use.
In a thinner wall, we can
reduce weight and cost
in the stove, which really
improves the last mile
distribution that Ethan
was talking about.
When you use you cast iron,
the stove gets pretty heavy.
And so for someone
on a motorcycle,
they can only carry one or two.
The next generation
of this thing
will be able to carry four,
maybe five, on a motorcycle,
and get the same
kind of durability
by using a higher performance
alloy rather than the cast
iron.
So it's a whole mix.
And we work really closely
with Oak Ridge National
Labs and their combustion
and corrosion lab
to really find the
optimum materials.
Typically, really
corrosion resistant,
heat resistant materials
are very expensive.
So it's another one of
these balancing acts
where we have to find the
right trade between cost
and durability.
I think we're really close.
With respect to your
financing question,
in our first year of operations,
all of our stoves sold
were with upfront cash.
So customers would
pay 50-odd dollars
in cash, which obviously is
a substantial amount of money
relative to incomes.
But to our surprise,
we sold stoves
faster than we had expected
a higher than modeled
retail price.
But we realized that
we were probably
only skimming the more affluent
parts of our target market.
And so starting in 2015,
we focused exclusively
on launching what we called
credit-enabled distribution
channels.
So these include banks,
microfinance organizations,
and producer cooperatives
that provide loans to farmers.
And in those models, the
flavors of financing vary.
But for instance, in India
our main microfinance partner
finances the stove for
$2 a month for two years.
And that obviously
has dramatically
widened the addressable
market of people that can
afford to purchase the stove.
AUDIENCE: Hey, there, guys.
Thanks for coming.
So a two-part question.
One is what's the
order of magnitude
of the number of stoves that
are in the hands of actual end
users.
And also, what's for you
guys the next 10x market?
Which market are
you most excited
about in the developing world?
RYAN GIST: I mean,
you got those numbers.
ETHAN KAY: So to date, we've
kept production and sales
to 15,000 units, in order to
A, validate product market fit
with customers, B, refine
our business model, and C,
figure out these questions
around financing.
With the launch of the new
stove that Ryan described,
we're going to
have a product that
is lower cost with
a stronger feature
set, which is timed for us to
start scaling our operations.
The plan is to continue to
remain in India and East Africa
as our core markets and
to sell a million stoves
over the next five years.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ETHAN KAY: Thanks.
RYAN GIST: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
RYAN GIST: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Let's
say someone who saw
this BioLite in the
YouTube or something
there and like thing,
someone in India.
And if they want to, let's
say, affiliate with you
or are an NGO member who
wants to publicize this.
What are the steps
that someone has
to go through to create
[? others of this ?]
or want to finance this
or sell these things?
Like that.
ETHAN KAY: Sure.
Well, firstly, to put
them in touch with us.
Especially with India
being a key market,
we'd be thrilled to talk to
any potential distribution
partners, marketing
partners, et cetera.
We currently have operations in
India in the state of Odisha,
which is in the east,
Rajastan, which is in the west,
and have also run operations
in the northeast in Assam,
Mizoram, Nagaland, et cetera.
And so we have teams on the
ground in each of those markets
who anyone in your
network who is interested
can reach out to through us.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: In terms
of size for people--
I mean, there have been
a number of technologies
that have been attempted to use
for this, like solar stoves.
How do you compare, in
terms of size of market
and in terms of
installed base, compared
to some of these
other things that
have been used for the reduction
in pollution and the like?
ETHAN KAY: Maybe I can start.
RYAN GIST: Go for it.
ETHAN KAY: And forgive
a bit of snark here.
As we were saying in the
talk, that taste of food
is really culturally specific.
And from my experience,
and there are exceptions,
but from my experience,
cooking on a solar stove
is the equivalent of trying
to microwave a steak.
And who wants to eat
a microwaved steak?
There are a few
problems with it.
One, you need a lot of sunlight.
And during the monsoon season,
for instance, in India,
or in the evening, that's
obviously a challenge.
Secondly, food takes
a really long time
to prepare on a solar cooker.
So it's like slow
cooking in the US.
So you put the food on in
the cooker in the morning.
You hope it stays sunny all day.
And in the evening,
you have food.
But for instance, you
can't make a roti,
a flat bread on a solar cooker.
And as I was
joking, you probably
wouldn't want to grill
your steak on one.
RYAN GIST: I mean,
you said it great.
I don't think there's too much
more to add to that, really.
ETHAN KAY: So yeah, so
solar cookers, I think,
are appropriate in some
contexts and have gained
some traction in some contexts.
But half the planet,
as we were saying,
cooks with wood, cow
dung, and crop waste.
And we really feel as a
business that our goal
is to meet users where they are
in terms of the types of fuels
that they have available, the
types of dishes that they like
to cook, and ensuring
that the taste is
consistent with the meals
that they prepared before
on an open fire.
AUDIENCE: So I
just had a question
about how much of a piece of
wood is, say, incombustible.
What is perfect?
And how close are you
to perfect when it
comes to combusting everything?
RYAN GIST: Sure.
I mean, wood is primarily carbon
and hydrogen, mostly carbon.
When we talk about
burning to completion,
we can burn all that carbon.
So there's maybe on an
average piece of wood 3% to 8%
that's mineral.
And that's the only part
that's actually not burnable.
So if you've ever seen the
leftovers after a fire,
there's a lot of
big black chunks,
which is the char or carbon.
And then there's little
bits of white, stringy,
spider-web-looking material.
And that white stuff
is mineral ash.
And that's the only
part of the wood
that's completely unburnable.
AUDIENCE: And does the
reduction in total carbon
ash effect uses that people
have for their stoves?
Do they have things
to do with the ash?
RYAN GIST: That's
a great question.
And we see that a lot,
although what happens
is in some households, they're
ready to utilize that charcoal.
And they may have a
specific charcoal stove
that they might use.
But in a lot of
homes, it just gets
disregarded and passed off.
So we feel like
it's better for us
to go ahead and
burn that charcoal
to completion, give them all
that heat energy for cooking.
If they still need
to purchase or create
charcoal for a different
cooking task, that's fine.
But I think we'd rather cover
all those instances where
people discard the charcoal.
AUDIENCE: And finally, you
said you were moving away
from cast iron to a different
alloy for the inner part?
RYAN GIST: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So will that hurt
your ability to produce, say,
the cast iron in country?
Or I don't know
how to describe it.
RYAN GIST: Yeah, I mean,
that's a fair question.
And for the specific alloy
we're looking at right now,
it would probably
have to be imported.
And then the
manufacturing of that
from sheet metal into finished
goods would happen in country.
But I think that could still
be a major improvement.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering if you
could provide just a few
technical specs, like what
is the total mass.
Is there a battery
in the orange unit?
And if so, what's its capacity?
What is the total power
output to the USB port?
Some other stuff like that?
RYAN GIST: Sure.
So currently, there is
no battery in the stove.
That adds cost,
again, to the product.
And so until we can bring
the rest of the cost down,
we're going to leave
the battery out.
We are working both in our
outdoor recreation markets
and in our emerging markets
on some lighting options that
can utilize the USB
power from the stove
to provide light, but also
have a battery on that side
of the system to store things.
So right now, there is no
battery storage capacity.
The USB output is
about 2 and 1/2 watts.
So that's very
comparable to say,
the side of your laptop when
it's not plugged into the wall.
If you just plug in
your phone on the side
your laptop to
charge your phone,
it's about the same kind
of current flow and power
that you see.
The next generation of the
stove will get another 20%, 25%
improvement in that.
AUDIENCE: And just the
total mass of the stove?
RYAN GIST: Currently, this is
around six to eight kilograms,
I believe.
And the next one will cut
that significantly down
below five kilograms.
AUDIENCE: And are you worried,
as a possible perverse outcome
of this, that people
will burn wood
that they otherwise
would not have,
just to charge their phone?
RYAN GIST: That's
definitely a concern.
I know Ethan and his team
have looked into that.
ETHAN KAY: So, yeah.
This was an initial
concern of ours.
And after several
years of operations,
not only have we never
seen that happen,
but there is a PhD student at
Lawrence Berkeley Lab named
Danny Wilson who did an
independent evaluation where
he designed a stove
usage monitoring system.
It was actually
to our camp stove,
which is a product that wasn't
even designed for this market.
And he looked at
whether people are
using a camp stove for
charging and not for cooking.
And again, that product
wasn't even designed
for cooking in that market.
And what he found was not only
were people not using the stove
just for charging.
The version of the
stove that had charging,
households were using
it way more for cooking.
So the inclusion of the
electricity generation
actually increased
usage for cooking,
while they were
co-generating power,
but did not have the perverse
effect of customers using it
just for charging.
AUDIENCE: And as I often see
with really cool products
like this, it's just not
available for purchase here,
for people who want to
play around with it.
Like, can I go out and buy that?
ETHAN KAY: So in response
to people like you,
we launched, I guess, last year?
RYAN GIST: 2014.
ETHAN KAY: 2014, middle
of 2014, a version
of this product called the
BaseCamp, which is essentially
a backyard barbecue.
So it has the same
chassis or body of this.
But it has a
different top, which
can be used both for
grilling and as a stove.
You flip a lever.
And it switches back and
forth between a diffuse flame
for making a bunch of burgers
and a concentrated flame
for making soup.
It also has legs on
it so that you don't
have to crouch on the ground.
It has a battery on board.
It produces twice as much
power as this version.
And we launched that
product on Kickstarter.
And I think it was the 20th
most successful Kickstarter
product in Kickstarter history.
So you can go either
to our website
or to REI or any other
outdoor retail store
to buy the BaseCamp.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ETHAN KAY: Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks, gents.
RYAN GIST: Yeah, thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]